*Music playing*
Aw, man
I don't like to talk about politics on my channel...
and i don't think i'll ever reveal who i'm voting for
Casey : "So i..if your favourite youtuber.."
"..says things like.."
"..I don't like to talk politics on my channel.."
"..or i'm not gonna reveal who i'm voting for.."
*echoing sound*
"Call them out"
Owh
Americans are so self-centered
of course
That they think this whole election is about the entire universe
and that's all that matters
so OF COURSE
All the top 20 youtubers needs to be called out
But you know what ?!
I'LL TELL YOU THIS !
IF I COULD VOTE..
My vote.. *pointing finger to the camera*
*echoing sound* Would be for Björne !
FORM BJÖRNES MAGASIN !
Did Björne ever sexually harass anyone ?
NO
HE DID NOT
Probably..*uncertain face*
Did Björne from Björnes Magasin..
ever sent drones to kill anyone ?
NO !
Drones weren't invented..
Back in Björnes era !
BJÖRNE !
will be a great fucking president
And I will be casting my vote
ON HIM
I really encourage you..
to make the same vote..
at this election
I think if we all work together..
we can make it so...
Not Trump will happen..
..or not Hillary..
..or either one of those
VOTE BJÖRNE
DA BEAR
FROM BJÖRNES MAGASIIIN..
HE WILL SET US FREE..
..AND HE WILL DO A GREAT JOB
I feel confident that he will do a better job than the two current candidates
I'm just so glad
That with my influence..
I can have a positive..
errr..
influence on..
..errr..
..the election
*drink from a chinese jug*
You know I do a lot of charity work..
..and I do it..
..now I'm getting involved in politics..
..and I think Björne...
..he's gonna make everything better
He is Swedish..
..and he is a fictional character
But..
comparing him to the rest I think it's pretty reasonable..
and I think with my 48 MILLION SUBSCRIBERS..
which are all totally..
eeerrrrmmm..
they're all active..
If ALL of them vote, think about that for a second..
If ALL of them vote Björne..
WE'D HAVE OUR NEW PRESIDENT EVERYONE
Björne from Björnes Magasin
I want you to think about that..
and I want you to go and vote
It doesn't matter if you can't vote..
which clearly seems to be the case here
I want you to vote anyway, on Björne from Björnes Magasin
I don't even know if he's still alive..
it was a long time ago..
lemme double check it..
björn björn björn..
Is he still alive ?
eeeeerrrrmmmm...
uuuhhhhmmmmmm..
*holding laughter*
Why don't I watch this fucking, bear..
*snot*
But that's not what this video's about !
I have some much more important things to discuss
than about..
I actually meant that..
ummmm..
Listen.. listen to this..
much more important
MY GOLDEN PLAY BUTTON
WAS BROKEN !
It was sent to me in broken pieces !
Show the clip of that
Pewds : "Like what I'm gonna, it is clearly trash.."
"Like, what I'm gonna do with it ?"
Pewds : "I'm legit pissed" *Starts laughing*
So I had to se..sell it for 5 pounds
Luckily now, I manage to live
But I had to sell my most prize possession, my golden play button
Cue the i sold it...
..Theme
*sad music*
Oh I'm so, argh..
It hurts
It fucking hurts you know
to..to let go something that you love
It's practically..
as if..
Leo, had to sell his oscar *fading out whistle sound*
Because he ran out of money
Can you imagine..
that happened to me..
Pewdiepie
THE BIGGEST YOUTUBER
OOOOOOHHHHHH
IT HURTS
*slow-mo poods*
(plz comeback you golden play button)
AND I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE THINKING !
"Pewdz, you have the diamond play button.."
"why do you care ?"
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND !
Marc "Bulletball" Griffin : "You don't understand.."
You..you don't understand
Zoomed-in Marc "Bulletball" Griffin : "You don't understand.."
The golden play button, is all that matters..
THAT'S what really..
people care about
The diamond play button, didn't even come with the fraameee..
The golden play button and the silver play button, has a fraaameee..
What am I gonna do ? I can't put this on the wall !
*Glass breaking*
Yea
I was so happy when they announce the golden play button..
but now I realize now, I would never have one !
They promise that they would send me a new one !
But they never do it !
Am I gonna have to wait two years again ???
Owh..
*sniffing*
OH..
OUFH
It's a new hashtag !
OWH !
HUUUH
HAASHHHTAAG
*giggle*
#goldenplayforpewds *Please spam it everywhere*
OOOOH, THIS IS GONNA TREND
All the..all the Google CEO will saw, they're gonna tremble !
But NO
I'm not one for petty trah..hashtags and games
I HAVE A BETTER IDEA
TOGETHER
WE'RE GONNA MAKE
A NEW CHANNEL !
IT'S GONNA BE CALLED..
I'm gonna link this channel in the description
And if all of us..
ALL 48 MILLION OF US
Can go and click on this link
That would not just generate 40 millio..8 million views..
Which will be a really a nice for ad revenue
But it would also give me..
A NEW GOLDEN PLAY BUTTON
So if all my subscribers..
If all my..
BROS
Come together
And click on this link
We can change the f..world
For 4 years
Am I mixing them u... I...
Check out my new, channel
Like and subscribe
There's gonna be a lot of new fresh content
Coming on my second channel
I'm gonna do vlogs
ah..daily vlogs
Which i will do for a couple months and I will probably get bored
and I'll forget about the channel
But then whenever someones wants to..
hype me up, they'll say..
"Oh well Pewdiepie, he has 48 million subscribers.."
"And 1 million subscribers on this one.."
"So he has 49 million subscribers"
You know that make no fucking sense
Do you hate jacksepticeye?
Well then this is the channel for you!
*Explosion*
(Jackseptic sucks)
Share your hatred for this irish potato looking man with...
The community of jacksepticeye sucks!
(Jackseptic sucks again)
Get new friends, and connect with them online!
(Jackseptic sucks AGAIN)
If this channel gets 1 million subs jacksepticeye will delete his channel!